so welcome to
this first time inaugural digital
medicine symposium here at Yale my name
is Greg Nicolai I teach at the School of
Management as adjunct faculty I'm also a
chief medical officer and chief medical
information officer for a large public
company and I've worked in health care
throughout my life and also a graduate
of the Yale School of Medicine today we
today we wanted to bring a discussion of
digital medicine to Yale in in order to
really stimulate some thought and really
begin to lay the foundation and explore
what is digital medicine but but perhaps
more importantly why digital medicine
why now and why should we be
enthusiastic about it and to be to be
honest today started out as a little bit
of a pilot a little bit of an experiment
really testing the waters to see what
was the level of interest in in the Yale
community and we had an overwhelmingly
positive response from both from from
the audience well we'll be expecting
people to be kind of wandering in
throughout the day as well as from
sponsors and you know willing to help
fund this and and our collaborators
who've really done a terrific job
and and again that kind of brings us
back to the question why why the
overwhelming response and and why why
the interest at this point and I guess
the other you know key key thing to to
mention is that this is the first Yale
digital medicine symposium in about a
month
there is a Harvard digital medicine
symposium so we're very happy to I take
the lead and allow our colleagues and
Cambridge to be fast followers so so why
did little medicine and and really in a
phrase digital medicine is about patient
empowerment
empowering patients with more choices
more information and really bringing
bringing the the health care which was
previously in the hands of a small group
of incumbents doctors insurance
providers etc into the hands of patients
why do you medicine where where does
some of these promises come from today
we'll hear examples on how digital
medicine is improving all these things I
mean really it's a it's a stunning
series of possibilities you'll hear
about talk space is improving access as
well as reducing stigma in behavioral
health and depression and and other
other types of mental disorders you'll
hear about AI is improving the use of
personalization as well as building a
stronger evidence base for for medicine
we'll talk about the use of data and out
to generate better outcomes which will
also create but better evidence for a
wider more representative population
we'll hear about how the collaboration
between Apple and Johnson & Johnson -
the most recognized names in healthcare
or just who the most recognized brand
names have come together to create a
sweeping offering for patients you know
- for more convenience about about
healthcare and and the the evidence is
there perhaps this is one of the most
welcomed surprises that digital medicine
actually produces clinical results and
you know just to mention some of the
examples diabetes measurable
improvements in diabetes care measure
measurable improvements
in asthma treatments and respiratory
disease measurable survival in lung
cancer for patients who use digital
disease management apps but in order to
get there we have to proceed responsibly
so part of the mission here is not just
to talk to to this audience about what
the promises are but really to send out
a sense of urgency that that in order
for this new feel to progress standards
need to be met and those standards are
not to encumber progress but actually to
help deliver progress to create a
foundation of better sense of security
and a better sense of confidence that
safety exists quality exists we need an
interdisciplinary approach between
medicine business technology educate the
stakeholders and we need innovative
business models to be able to pay for
this and to achieve the promises that
that we want to we want to get so today
so today's audience or today's target
audience if you will is the the non
expert in digital medicine but people
who are informed and care deeply about
health care and want to learn and think
about the promises the that what did the
definitions we'll go over briefly what's
the status of the progress in the field
of digital medicine and implicit here
will be some of the promises that that
we mentioned suffice to say that digital
healthcare digital medicine is a
complicated landscape everything from
mobile apps personalized healthcare
telemedicine etc will be focused more on
digital therapeutics and some of the
other enablers you know we'll be talking
about drug supply chain
as as an enabler but this entire field
is moving forward with really an
impressive speed again why digital
medicine digital medicine has clinical
impact Digital saw a software healthcare
software has been really putting up some
impressive results we'll we'll hear a
little bit later on about behavioral
health software that is that is creating
you know promises for in treatment of
ADHD as well as other other types of
behavioral disorders as mentioned
diabetes etc lung cancer survival why
why is this happening now part of it is
because there is there have been some
landmark approvals coming from the FDA
and and even in drug adherence which you
know my colleagues in medicine that know
that this has been a very difficult area
to to get our heads around and to create
benefits even in drug adherence using
digital technology and a whole
wraparound system have demonstrated a
benefit of improving adherence in
patients who are defined as medically
refractory to treatment not not
psychologically or and not you know
disorganized but medically refractory
patients had clinical benefits once they
improved their adherence and you know
and and the opportunity for public
health management in monitoring disease
and air quality for asthma and it's not
stopping with this there's a host of
other programs that are moving forward
in digital medicine sleep cognitive
training etc etc digital medicine also
has regulatory acceptance so the FDA in
recent years has really been very
forward-thinking there
progressive about assuring this new era
starting with the 20th century 21st
century cures act I'll go through these
as a number of quick examples because
there's really just too many to belabor
the 21st century cures at led to the
digital health innovation Action Plan in
2017 a pre certification program which
keeps on being updated most recently
this year as well as a new approach
certifying artificial intelligence
products
and as well as a commitment to
real-world evidence which is is has to
be enabled using different digital
databases and digital techniques and
finally digital medicine is well funded
part of the reason that that us you know
all of us who have been observers of
this digital transformation have been
waiting for this to happen well you know
follow the money so its projected to be
over a two hundred billion dollar market
in the next decade venture funding is up
the consumer market for for data which
we'll hear about shortly is it is
growing very rapidly as well as
artificial intelligence and if you just
look at the numbers you know they speak
for themselves a thirty percent
year-over-year increase in venture
funding increasing deal sizes an
increasing number of deals in in digital
healthcare so so why digital medicine
digital medicine as we said is about
patient empowerment but I actually
struggled with with what this actually
means because it's really not about the
digital it's not even about the medicine
and it's not even in my opinion about
the patient it's about the empowerment
and what I mean is that in the near
future we're not going to be talking
about digital medicine we will be
talking about this as the standard of
care as a standard of practice and
ultimately it's because organizations
that are interested in healthcare are
shifting their focus to
what is engaging patients when you hear
the CEO of CVS and Aetna talk about what
was what was the main driver of a
seventy billion dollar merger their
answer was patient engagement when when
you look at what is funding artificial
intelligence and why insurance companies
are pouring billions of dollars their
answer is patient engagement because
we're at the era where we're seeing
power shifting from the incumbents from
physicians from payers from health
systems where we used to you own the
information we used to own the decision
and we forced it on in almost a
belittling way calling you patients who
could not be involved in your decision
of of healthcare the shift is
empowerment of all of us so that we all
can engage and participate in healthcare
to actually become the people providing
our own healthcare that's why I think we
should all be hopeful and very
cautiously optimistic about about that
future so that being said let's move on
to the discussion we will try to save
time for a couple of questions at the
end of each end of each talk will will
talk about data and outcomes we will
talk about use of artificial
intelligence drug supply therapeutics
and we we have to give time to think
about the ethical considerations and the
responsibility that we all have and
before I'll ask Harlan to come up I just
want to say thank you to our organizers
who've done a terrific job particularly
cbut and and you know here we are in
this gorgeous building at the at the
Yale Law School as well as our sponsors
including a Medtronic Stewart health
health Haven hub
health care ventures as well as a PRA
health and a little bit of a plug for a
future pitch competition coming up
sponsored by health haven hub and health
ventures which is our homegrown digital
medicine incubator and venture fund